> WELCOME TO "THE ."JA T HEALTHU
IN LIF WFOE STD CHAN.
YOU AREUL VACCINEHE
YOUANNDOORS
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WILL JOIN ME S
T OMENT BIDECELEBRATED THE MOVTE
HEY CAN GO WHO
IF FULLY VACCINATED.GRLESTON
A GREAT Y.
IT'S BEEN MADE POSSIBY THERDAR T
T VACCINATED, YODID.E AMERICAN
URY.
THAT'S HHA GOTTEN
THIS>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO
ANTHONY FAUCI.
IS ESSENTIALLY OVEIN THE
E,T GO SO
FA TO SAY IT'S EEN
STEP IN THE CTOME DEGREE OF
NORMALITY BECAUSE THIS IS
MES
YOU KNOW, I'M
TREND?START THINGS A OR
AND BEING ABLE TUN
WITHOUT A MASK INDOORS AS WELL
ASORS IS REALLG STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION.
SOO DECLARE
VIAT I'M S IS CLEARLY A STEP IN
GO.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
PARENTS WHO ARE OUT THERE I'M V
MY KS E NOT, BUTHE
THEM GET TY
LOW.
D YOU TELL THEM, NO, NO,
THE KIDSTO
>> YEAH, THELDN
SITUATION.ING WITH THEIR FRIEANN
THEY DO, BUT, YOU KNOW, ONE OFT.
BYHE PFIZER VACCINE.  VACCINATE
40% O
NOT FULLVACCINATED.
SOME ARE PARTIALLY.Y TO TRACK W
VACCIN.THERE'S A LOT OF RESISTA
F VACCINE RT,
T E RESTAURANTS,
AIRLINES, OTHERS, SUPPOSED TO G
THEIR ESTABLISHMENTS OVEHICLES
E A RIGHT TO DO WHATEVER
BUT T THEDC IDANCE
WEARING
>> WELL, JAKE, THEY WILL NOT B
ABLE T AND YOU'RE
DEPENDING ON PEOPL
ENY THEY'RREON
A MASK. THEIR OWN
PRECTION, BUT ALSO FOR THE
PROTECTION OF .BY THE WAY, HOUGW
SA
TI JAKE, WE WILL NOT BE
GOING TO BE  CLEARLYPORTDEL
THAT ARE GOING TO BE SAYING AND
THAT COULD BE AIRLINES KNOW
CERE
IF YOU'RE NOINATED, YOU'RE
COME S INEAEY'RE GOING TO BE -E
ARE GOG
INTHE SAME  GOVERNMENT
'T BE MANDATINTO HA  PROVING YO
VACCINATED THERE MAY BOR
>> DO YO PLACE
ASTO PHARMACIES,WHATEV A
VAED PEOPLE TO COM AUT MASES.
ABSOLUTEAN, TH'S
NG VACCINATED PEOPLE ILOOK AKED,
WHAT'S CHANGED?E
ACCUMULATED NOW IS TT CLEARLION.
DAY RIGHT NOW, WHICH HAS GONE
DOWN ABO A THIRD.
AS YOU MENTIONED OF OPLE
T ONF A
D GREATER THAN 40% ARE
FULLCC SO E
SITUATION HAS CHANGED AND
THERE'
HAVE PEOPLE WEARG MASKS.E IN
YOU'R -
ASK YOY ANIES
ASK YONGF THEYD
PEOPLE AT THE DOOR TO MAKEUR
WITH THESE
NEW GUIDELINES, WHAT WOULD YOU
LL>> THAT'S GOING TO BE
RE
USRY
E BA
EYWE WANT PEOPLE TO GET VACCINA.
BUT THK THER
A  QUESTIONING
SOMEBODY WHEN THEYALK IN.
CAR VALIDATE
OR PROVE THAT THEY'RE IN
THEN YOU GETO THE SITUATIO THA
SOMEONE SAYS YES, M IN.'S A FUN
EQUIVALENT OF A VACCINE PASSPORT
T THINK THAT'S GOING
TO
>> AND C
VE MASK MANDATES IN PLACE.
SHOULD LOCALGOVERNMENTS DROP THE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED?
>> WELL,O ARE
VACCINATED THAS T E GOIN
FIND, FROM A PUB
ANINCE CAN  V
SOMEONE'S VACCINATED AGAINST NDO
THAT, IF YOU DROP MAAT
SEFECTION AMONG WHARINATED.
SO THAT'S KIDIY IO
YOU'RE TINCY LOCAL LEVEL WHEN
IGHEISSION.
MAKE.  NOT AN EASY DEC
>>NES ARILL MAWHY?
I MEAN, Y  -
JU ADVOCATE
COND.
IF I DON'T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK H
M FULLCCINATED,
WHY DO I HAVE TO WEAR ONE IF I ?
>> AGAIN, THAT'S GOINGAN ISSUE
BE DISCUSSED.
WHAT THE HASCLEAR,
THEY'RGOTOT  HAVE YOU. ABOUT ANN
ASKED YOITH A E YOU SWER THE QUT
NES TH
EAT AT IS TORE NOT GNGO GET ON
PLANE UNLESS YOU CAN PROVE YOUHI
DO THAT. MEAN, I DON'RLI
VACCINATED.
I HAVE A CARD OM GEORGETOWN  WNY
VACCINE
>> WHAT DOOULE --
SORRY.
>> NO,EAD.
O --
YEASE.
>> SO WE HAVE VACCINE SKEPTICS
HAVEIS IS TOO MUCH TOO THE PROCS
WHAT DU SAY TO THEM? WEXE RATIOF
WHAT WE'REWE WANT VIRTUAY
RELAXATI OREOING NOW
PE WHE VACCINATED ING TO O A D
THAT THINGS
G TO'S BEEN THNCET
BE AN TCHANGE THAT .PEOPLE WHOA
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO GE
THE DECI TMADE
PES ET
COULD ACTUALLY HAVE THE INDIREC
CEO GEED.
N OFS H CD WALENSKY D THE PRESI
ARE SCHOOLE FALL SHOULD BEND
IN PERSO FIVE DAYS A A'S THE
PREPARING?ORMALIZED SOSCHOOLS AR
>> YEAH.THE DAYS, JUTHE WAY IT T
CA T>> AND IF THE KIDSANIF THE